Das war's für heute.
Come on!
mit irgendwelchen alten YouTubern von früher, Relatycellen.
Relatycellen, oder Fabian, aber mit Fabian hatte ich auch schon Kontakt vorher.
Wir müssen noch das Ganze übrigens gleich noch auf Twitter posten.
Also, wir haben jetzt die Auswahl, bei Musik heute wie gesagt.
Wir können ein bisschen Kirby wieder doodeln lassen, bis wir durchdrehen im Kopf.
Oder wir machen ein bisschen Power-Metal an.
Was ich heute nicht anmache, wo ich heute keinen Bock drauf hab,
ist irgendwelche Chillstep-Geschichten. So, Settings.
Ich wollte euch irgendwas zeigen. Ich wollte euch gerade irgendwas zeigen.
Ich bin voll vergessen. Ich hab doch gerade gesagt, ich wollte euch irgendwas zeigen.
Was wollte ich euch denn zeigen? Ich hab's immer vergessen.
Ja, Raw Input. Stimmt denn?
Stimmt dann? Ja, Borderless, 144 Hertz, das ist gut.
Feel of You, Formula 80, das ist auch gut.
Chromatic Apparation, alles aus.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was es ist, aber erst mal aus.
Hauptsache, es ist das Wichtigste. Erst mal aus.
Power-Metal, yeah.
So. Leider. Ich wollte ja die neue Map spielen, ne?
Ich zeig euch, zeig das mal hier.
Leider gibt's die neue Map nicht.
Map, komm her. Rotterdam? No servers.
Gibt kein. Gibt kein Rotterdam zum Spielen.
Woher hast du die Alpha? Das ist doch gar nicht die Alpha.
Das ist die Open Beta.
Das Spiel hat aber mittlerweile mehr Bugs.
So, also ich hab gestern schon ein bisschen gespielt.
Ich bin jetzt hier im Medic Level 7. Das ging relativ schnell.
Kann man sich eigentlich seine Stats irgendwo angucken?
Kann man sich... Oh, das ist jetzt interessant.
Kann man sich seine Stats irgendwo angucken?
Stats? Wo sind die Stats?
Man kann auf Rotterdam spielen, ist nur verbackt.
Ja, aber wenn ich im Serverbrowser nicht Rotterdam auswählen kann,
wie kann ich dann auf Rotterdam spielen?
Versteh ich nicht.
Aber gestern kam auch, es kam nur, es kam nur Navig.
Es kam gestern nur.
Okay, Moment. Wo könnte ich meine Stats sehen?
Okay, Moment, Moment. Ich muss auch kurz Kirby wegmachen.
So, also wir können, wir können, wir können Dings anmachen,
wir können Hammer voll anmachen, wir können...
Oh, übrigens, mein neues Power Metal Technik.
Also für die ganzen Metal Leute hier.
Übelsgeiles Album hier.
Ich meine, klingt schon Power Metal-mäßig,
also viel mehr Power Metal kann man nicht klingen.
Ich meine, wenn man Rise of the Chaos Results heißt,
von einer Band, die sich Glory hammern hat,
mehr Power Metal geht eigentlich gar nicht.
Oh, viel zu laut, viel zu laut.
Aber übelsgeil.
Conquest Server wechseln immer nach jeder Runde.
Oh man, das ist nur verbackt.
Ich sag doch, mehr Bugs,
mehr Bugs als die Alpha.
Habt ihr Quali-Settings?
Habt ihr keine Quali-Settings?
Warte mal, das muss ich mal kurz, muss ich mal kurz refreshen.
Warum habt ihr keine, ihr solltet ja Quali-Settings haben.
Nee, ihr habt keine Quali-Settings.
Ja, ja, sorry, kann ich nichts machen?
Ich hab mal Quali-Settings, aber ich hab keine Quali-Settings.
Wahrscheinlich streamen gerade zu viele Leute.
Pech gehabt.
Nee, kann ich, kann ich nichts machen.
Ich hab halt nur zur Auswahl, ich kann hier runterstellen.
Also ne, ich stream halt gerade mit 7,5, 8 Mbit.
Mittlerweile unterstützt das Twitch so.
Und nachdem ich nicht gepartnert bin und nix,
und auch immer noch nix gemacht hab in der Richtung,
ist halt die Sache, mag krieg ich Quali-Settings
und mag krieg ich keine Quali-Settings,
obwohl es halt immer die gleichen Settings sind.
Oh, ja, ein bisschen Hände aufwärmen, ey.
Conquest.
Wir spielen jetzt erst noch mal ein paar Runden,
zumindest war es zu warm,
wir spielen jetzt noch mal ein paar Runden Operation.
Immer noch grausame,
immer noch grausame Map,
also sowohl von den Spawn-Punkten her als auch mit,
übrigens der Sound ist an, ich hab bloß die Musik weg.
Das ist übelst geil.
Power-Metal Beste.
Ja, meine Meinung zum Spiel bis...
Übrigens, wie ist Musik-Lautstärke zu mir?
Passt das so?
Also ich werd die Musik beim Spiel ein bisschen leiser machen,
vor allem wenn ich mich konzentrieren muss.
So, ähm...
Ja, also meine Meinung zum Spiel bisher.
Ich hab mir sogar extra was aufgeschrieben.
Lautstärke perfekt, wunderbar.
Also ich hab mir extra was aufgeschrieben zu dem Spiel,
weil falls ich ein Video machen sollte, ja.
Also, ähm...
Oh, es geht los.
Ich find das Spiel immer noch schlecht.
Ich sag aber nicht einfach nur schlecht,
ich kann es auch noch begründen,
weil was euch wahrscheinlich mehr interessiert,
als dass ich es einfach schlecht finde.
Ich kann es allerdings aktuell nur für Operations sprechen
und auch nur für Navig-Operations,
weil was anderes konnte ich auch nicht spielen.
So, das ist auch ne Sache, die mir auf den Sack geht,
diese Intros.
Immer die Intros, die ganze Zeit die Intros
und du kannst sie nicht wegklicken.
Mir gehen die Intros jetzt schon auf den Sack.
Dark Galactic Sky.
So, auf geht's.
So, zweiter Tag.
Das heißt, wir haben wahrscheinlich
die erste Runde übrigens auf den Sack gekriegt.
Ähm, also die Map ist grausig.
Sowohl von Spawns her als auch,
weil wir wollen Medic spielen.
Sowohl von den Spawns her als auch von den Map-Begrenzung.
Jetzt müsst ihr immer bloß noch dabei...
Squad?
In Item.
Krass gelootet, klar.
Wenigstens geht das Squad-Join mittlerweile schon.
Wir sind am zweiten.
Ach so, was übrigens auch nicht mehr geht,
ist das hier, was ich übrigens kacke finde.
Das ging bisher in so ziemlich jedem Battlefield,
was man...
Also vor allem Bad Company 2.
Bad Company 2 war eh geil, da bist du...
Christisch, Alter.
Oh, oh, oh, Moment.
Sensitivity stimmt nicht.
Die hab ich hier noch nicht eingestellt.
NA-Aim.
Aber ich hab ihn, oder?
Hab ich ihn?
Nee, ich hab ihn nicht.
Man bleibt übrigens immer noch an dem ganzen Scheiß hängen.
Also hier.
Man bleibt hier immer noch an jedem...
Laufen, seht ihr gleich, wenn ich hier hochlaufe.
Man bleibt hier immer noch an jedem Scheiß hängen.
Alter, springen.
Das ist so schlimm.
Das...
Oh.
OK.
Den retzen wir jetzt.
Wo muss man überhaupt hin, Alter?
OK.
Ja, also was sag ich zum Game?
Das ist...
Also auf dieser Map zumindest.
Es gibt keine klaren Fronten.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Die Mapbegrenzung sind komisch.
Die Spawnpoints sind komisch.
Die Progression auf der Map ist komisch.
Das Ding ist so ein Hybrid aus Conquest und Rush.
Und davon irgendwie nix, nix gescheit.
Man kennt nicht richtig, wo die Auszonen sind.
Und das Hüppen funktioniert halt immer noch nicht.
Und das geht mir halt richtig auf den Sack.
Ich versuche hier mal Yolo-Rets zu machen.
OK.
Und da gibt es immer so kleine Bugs, wie ihr gerade gesehen habt.
Zwischendurch, dass man dann hängen bleibt oder irgendwie die Aktion nicht ausgeführt
wird oder so.
Und dann verreckt man dadurch immer halb.
Das ist so sehr, sehr...
Merkwürdig.
Man hat auch viel zu wenig Munition.
Guck mal.
Da ist nix gemacht.
Im Endeffekt, die Munition ist schon leer.
Es stehen auch nicht...
Es stehen auch keine Munitionskisten in Reichweite, dass man sagen könnte...
Klop.
Das ist meiner.
Ich weiß nicht so genau, wo er ist.
Piss dich mal.
Ach so, unser Gegner.
Irgendwo hier ist einer.
Nehmen wir das Ding mal auf.
Ist das ne Shotgun?
Nee, das ist ne Thompson oder sowas, ne?
Sektor.
Übrigens.
Wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist?
Woran man sieht, dass ich relativ viel Overwatch gespielt habe in meinem Leben.
Es hängt einfach.
Es hat einfach jetzt hängen geblieben.
Ähm.
Ja, ich weiß hier...
Nee, das ist keine Muni.
Die Muni-Kiste ist das.
Das ist die Idee.
Woran man sieht, dass ich relativ viel Overwatch geschrieben habe, ist dieser Tick.
Seht ihr was?
Dieser Tick.
Das haben alle Overwatch Spieler an diesem Tick.
Was bin ich eigentlich jetzt?
Ich bin Support, ne?
Ja.
Nee.
Medik?
Ich glaube, ich bin Support.
Übrigens, ich muss Dings umstellen.
Schuss.
Viel besser mit diesen Dingern immer Single-Schuss zu machen.
Weil die meisten Waffen so krass verziehen, dass du keine Chance hast über Range.
Mit der habe ich jetzt noch nicht gespielt.
Ja, in CS macht man es auch.
Aber Overwatch ist ganz extrem.
Hallo?
Leg dich hin.
Ah!
Ich habe falsch gemapped.
Sekunde.
Leute, warte mal.
Ich muss...
Ah, leg dich hin.
Ich muss ummappen.
Fuck.
Keybindings.
On foot prone.
Nee.
Crouch.
Prone.
Prone will ich.
Ich habe mich verdrückt hier.
Prone.
Ja, ja.
Was?
Nein.
Äh.
Clear.
Perfekt.
Ich habe immer...
Ja.
Hinschmeißen bei Battlefield auf rechter Maustaste.
Moin, Apollo X-Plane.
Du bist Cyrus-Sub, oder?
Sind das nicht Cyrus?
Emoats?
Fuckwaffe.
Lege Hände mal, jetzt.
Guck mal, wie das habt ihr gesehen, wie das hin und her wackelt.
Das ist auch wieder so was.
Wo du dich teilweise denkst, da fuck.
Wie soll's denn so...
Wie willst du denn so so schießen, teilweise?
Naja, so rumwackelt.
Hier ist einer.
Halt die Hände.
Schieße.
sowieso schießen teilweise
er so rum wackelt
hier ist einer
übrigens das ist das best was man
machen kann in diesem battlefield
alle autowaffen erstmal auf singelschutz stellen
und dann halt
bis zum zielen
übrigens gestern
ich hab's ja auf twitter gepostet
jede runde oder fast jede runde
irgendwie 55 56 sonst was
gibt es
über uns
weg
ich stehe hier relativ
unglücklich
ja ich stehe hier echt
relativ ungünstig
naja und das spotten ist auch
ganz merkwürdig
ich sag euch gleich nach der runde sag ich euch
ich hab mir nämlich ein bisschen was aufgeschrieben zu dem game
falls wie gesagt
falls ich dazu ein video mach
supression das ist einfach mal die richtung
von da oben kommt was
hekt
oh ne ich bin ja kein medic
bin ich doch medic
was bin ich überhaupt weiß nicht mal was ich bin
oh mega lol
übrigens
achter ping nahezu unspielbar
moment ich hab zu wenig fps
ich hab zu wenig fps da stimmt fast nicht
ach ja
deswegen hab ich zu wenig
es gibt jetzt ein neues setting
minimal latency
beste
hat man auch ordentlich fps dann
und das spiel hat übrigens
zwei spawn bugs aktuell
und die sind so schlimm
dass man dadurch quasi die komplette runde
nicht mehr spawnen kann
man bleibt drin aber man kann die komplette runde
nicht mehr spawnen
was ziemlich das sack ist
so wir flanken jetzt mal hier außen rum
moment
ich muss mal kurz überlegen
ach wir sind noch gar nicht am letzten
wir sind ja noch gar nicht am letzten
oh der hat voll den kopf gekriegt
die smg sind übrigens
auch auf range richtig schwach
weiß nicht ob die in der alpha auch schon so schwach waren
aber diesmal sind die smgs
übelst räudig auf range
ich hab dem grad dreimal den kopf geschossen
und so hat der 53 damage gekriegt
und was immer noch ist man kriegt random
headshots so
du läufst jetzt hier rauf und bumm
aber irgendwie von der seite weggeschneibert
so als hammers
ach haben sie das jetzt
gefixt ducky ok also gestern
war das noch und ich konnte
ich konnte auch
ich konnte auch gar nicht mal so richtig
ins menü
flankerino
give ammo
ammo
piss dich
self heal das ist auf 5
ich hab noch nicht gefunden also man kann sich
auf 5 self healen die sache ist ich hab noch
nicht gefunden wie man diesen knopf
umlegen kann weil ich würd den knopf gerne umlegen auf
zweite maustaste
hängen bleiben
au
au sind panzer irgendwo am start
nix wie weg
nix
1080p 1080
ich hab nur 1080
nur in anführungsstrichen
next please
es müsste eine brandgranate sein
nix da
oh da ist was drinne
der will gebashed werden
oder auch nicht
oh
kommt was
das
guckt so diese krasse
dinger so fest von der seite immer gebashed
ich hab leider die
aufnahmen nicht auf einer platte wo ich drauf zugreifen
kann so ich hatte gestern den
ultra geilen clip
am anfang hier vorne links
hab ich irgendwie gefühlt 8 leute weggesprayed
das war sehr sehr nice
respawn respawn respawn
nope oh da fährt ein auto rum
vielleicht darf ich ja respawn
aber man muss sagen
das spiel ist deutlich besser viel viel besser als battlefield 1
ging mir ja schon in der
weiß nicht ob es die alpha oder die beta
war so sehr offen sagt dass ich mir gedacht habe
ich kaufe mir das game gar nicht
in der form würde ich mir aktuell
das game auch nicht kaufen
es sei denn
es läuft es hat weniger bugs
weil ich meine es kann ja nicht sein dass du quasi schon das fünfte
spiel auf frostbite
basis im
endeffekt machen
und es immer noch so verbuggt ist
mein klar da sind immer
neue games aber die grundlage
ist doch die gleiche
das ist einer von mir
und fronten verlaufen sie kriegen sie immer noch nicht klar
auch sehr merkwürdig
in dem game
du weißt nur dass die
gegner irgendwo von da kommen
oder auch nicht
irgendwo von hier und jetzt kriege ich damage
und weiß nicht warum
aber flankerino machen wir jetzt mal
hüpf hüpf
ich dachte die kommt vielleicht hier her aber hier kommt nichts
hüpf
das ist übrigens auch übelst nervig
dieses rumgerollen
der gegner auf den boden
wenn sie schon eigentlich down sind
richtig nervig
Manchmal nicht was dauerndes und was nicht dauerndes
Vor welcher seite
Was machst was sagst du dazu dass rapper buschide und kollege anfangen auf twitch zu streamen glaubst du es hat zukunft die typen die sind so
populär so bekannt die können auf jeder plattform streamen und die konnten sogar auf auf
Mixer streamen und das würden leute gucken
Also ich bin ehrlich ich brauche jetzt buschide und kollega nicht unbedingt auf twitch
Haftbefehl wäre geil aber
Aber also ich brauche keine wappen verfahren machen die dann also letztendlich twitch ist ja im kerne
Alter wo ist denn hier immer was im kerne eine gaming plattform das darf man nicht vergessen
Was ey dieses game du weißt nie wo was ist
Ich habe keine Ahnung wo geht das denn gehen wir mal hier ins haus
Wo streamt er
Ich kann jetzt da nicht raus ich habe schiss
Ich mal habt ihr das gesehen wieder darum geklitscht ist gerade der soldat ich bin aus dem fenster gesprungen erst ich konnte erst mal
Eine halbe minute nicht eben nichts machen weil er hin und her gesprungen ist
Also ich bin jetzt auf dem fenster gesprungen
Nichts machen weil er hin und her gesprungen ist also ich habe keinerlei bewegung mit der maus gemacht gerade außer beim letzten auf den
Gegner eben
Das ging ja nicht so
Das hast du in dem game laufend du fühlst du hast man im game oft das gefühl du hast jetzt wenn du quasi
Aktion macht keine kontrolle mehr was zu machen wissen dann springt er und dann macht sein erst mal gefühlt fünf sekunden
Und dann kann man wieder was machen
In battlefield in bett company 2 welch aus dem fenster gesprungen beim beide tod
Hast du deine mein zu rainbow 6 geändert ja klar schon lange
Dachte ja noch während der alpha das oder wenn wir als damals als neu war dachte ja das wird der übelste reinfall
Aber ist es nicht gewonnen ziemlich gut mit der weile
Die
Seite rechts
Wo ist er
Legt sich hin
Ich hab doch da rechts irgendwo ein gesehen jetzt ist fertig aber wir sind spät gejohlen
Ja dudeldöner so ist es das ist das kommt die animationen sind übelst z
Und was wir halt legen auf diese zwischen intros
Er hat da kise und ist voll übertrieben mit animationen
Die was was sie geändert haben oder was mir zumindest so vorkommt ist dass die
Wiederbeleb animationen sind kürzer als in der alpha
Kannst du namen der bent in den chat schreiben glory hammer. Oh ja das darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen
glory hammer also glory und hammer
Was ist rise of the chaos wizards besser besser kann in power metal einfach nicht haben habe ich ein upgrade für medic gekriegt
Das ist auch eine sache die habe ich nicht verstanden
Gibt es dann später
Gibt es dann spät vielleicht weiß das jemand gibt es dann später noch mehr medic rollen die man auswählen kann
Weil ich mein aktuell jetzt bin ich ja medic level sieben und ich kann nur viel medic machen aber ich mein wenn es doch für
Die medic klasse quasi ein extra combat rolls menu gibt
Da muss es doch dann auch später mehr geben
Ja falsche animation bent company 2 runter gesprungen falsche im gut war
Und das nächste was ist mit diesem gadget hier warum kann ich das eigentlich
So ganz finde ich so ganz verstehe ich das menu also es ist ein bisschen umständlich
Aber es funktioniert schon deutlich besser als in der alpha
Ein converse spiele ich nicht irgendwas kriege ich immer also zustände
Dafür wird in operations richtig geklatscht
56 11
Weil ich sagen muss es ist anstrengender zu streamen und ordentlich zu spielen als nur ordentlich zu spielen
Das ist schon ganz schön unterschiedlich
Ja und viel zu wenig ammo kann ich dir recht geben
Es ist normal in dem game dass man nichts versteht also die frontlinien sind
Quasi zumindest hier auf navig operations quasi nicht vorhanden
Du weißt überhaupt nicht wo was passiert
Übrigens dass man was auch komisch ist dass man nicht anlocken kann während während des games
Also also das hier ich kann jetzt beispielsweise nicht während während die map wechselt oder so
Kann ich jetzt nicht mal kurz mal medic customize ich muss dann immer komplett raus
Was natürlich blöd ist jetzt überlegt überlegt man sich mal man spielt
Wie sieht man eigentlich seine stats wie sieht man seine stats
Jetzt überlegt euch mal ihr spielt im
Ja überlegt euch mal ihr spielt im squad
Okay machen wir jetzt einfach mal
Ja stell euch mal vor ihr spielt im squad und und laufen müsst ihr vom
Sauber runter weil irgendwer sein zeug customisieren will so nervig
Das ist weiß nicht irgendwie wo sieht man seine stats
Man muss doch irgendwie schwanz vergleich machen wo sieht man dann seine stats
Also ich würde sagen von der idee hier bei your company aber
Wer ist denn da noch online aber bei your company
Ich meine es wäre schön wenn man sich die stats angucken könnte zum beispiel pro
Klasse oder so aber das finde ich hier nicht als nächstes würde ich sagen
Armoury das ist aber auch keine stats
Wo kann ich mir stats angucken
Assignments aber Assignments ergibt eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn
Firefox auf
Zulang das game sucht
Battlefield 5 dazu gibt es schon eine Webseite
Das ist bestimmt Skamart das ist bestimmt fake
Achso ja irgendwas zum selbst installieren das ich den schönen Virus am start habe
Ganz bestimmt
Also ich bin also ich weiß nicht wie man in game stats angucken kann
Hier sind sind wir die fans wir sind die fans
Hallo
Also man sieht jetzt man weiß nicht warum der Bildschirm schwarz wird
Ah weil das intro kommen muss
Habt ihr auch Navig getakt
This is ein schön gefaketer deutsches accent
Jetzt hängt's game
Bestes Opening auf der Map
Zeige euch jetzt mal
Er klappt nicht immer
Immer noch intro übrigens man denkt man kann jetzt demnächst mal anfangen zu spielen
Aber so einfach ist es ja nicht
Ja
Manchmal man übrigens ist es auch nicht logisch wo man spawnen
Manchmal spawnen wir hier vorne bei dem Zug
Und manchmal spawnen wir da also man weiß es nicht so genau
Ja bestes Opening
Da bräuchte ein paar Leute hier vorne Dinge aufbauen
Das habe ich noch nicht gecheckt wie das geht
Man kann hier vorne barrikaden errichten ich weiß aber nicht wie es geht
Und ohne barrikaden ist hier vorne ziemlich kacke
Aber hier ist in der Regel bestes Opening für die Map und man kann
Wenn die hier drinnen sind kann man hier oben drauf klicken
Auch wenn die Animationen manchmal ein bisschen rumspacken
Also man kann eigentlich wenn die Animation geht kann man hier oben drauf
Glaubt ihr mir das geht
Ah jetzt geht's
Und dann kann man dann runter bashen
Ah guck da baut er
Der ist ein guter Mann
Er weiß Bescheid
Wie baut man
Man hat irgendwie einen Hammer
Hallo ich wollte dich gerade retten Kollege aber
Kein Bock
Da ist einfach so ein Ding vorm Kopf
Oh oh leg dich hin alter
Der kommt jetzt gleich hoch
Dann wird er gebashed
Okay oder auch nicht
Den müssen wir retten den müssen wir unbedingt retten
Hallo ich will retten
Guck habt ihr wieder gesehen die Rättsanimation funktioniert
Das ist ein ganz schöner Failbob
Kommt her
Und dieses eingeplänte ey kann man das ausschalten
Guck ich hab schon wieder keine Munition mehr
Oh nicht alle
Und es waren drei Headshots oder so juckt uns nicht
Who cares ha ha Headshot lol
Jetzt gehen wir jetzt mal mal Trick 17 Achtung
Komm her
Oh von der Seite kommt was
Ich sag euch beste Opening Position glaubt's mir
Und Pistolen Muni hat man genug
Ich bräuchte halt ein bisschen Munition das wär schon nicht schlecht
Munition ist halt komplett overrated
Ja warum man bei mir nur in 1080p schauen kann liegt daran das Twitch mir mal wieder
keine Qualitätsoptionen zugestanden hat
Ehh ich hab Muni
Nein hab ich nicht
Aber jetzt hab ich Muni
Und ist es Immersive
Er ist Immersive as fuck
Äh meine Maus ist weg meine Maus ist weg
Habt ihrs grad gesehen
Der Fokus von meiner Maus war weg
Ich konnte nicht umdrehen
Das Game ist mega verpackt
So muss das sein
Es ist einfach Maus Fokus weg gewesen gerade
Einfach so
So Bup
Darfst nicht mehr steuern
Hast so viele Kills gemacht
Darfst jetzt nicht mehr steuern
Overrated gebated ist das
Aber hier unten an den Zügen ist wirklich die beste
Die beste Opening Position überhaupt
Ich glaub da hinten steht einer kann das sein
Ich hab da einen gesehen
What the fuck
What wo in dem Game das hat keine Frontlinien
Ah Seite
Man hat zu wenig Munition
Ich mein wenn du ne gute Position hast ist halt übelst rollig
Wenn du permanent quasi weg musst und an irgendeine Kiste rennen
Guck mal du spawnst mit gerade mal 60 Munition bei einer SMG wohlgemerkt
Bei einer SMG 60 Schuss das ist nix
90 ok 3 Magazin ok aber 60
Plus ein Magazin schon dabei
Das ist nix
Und dass man an jedem Scheiß hängen bleibt
So wie hier jetzt
Warum?
Warum bleib ich hier hängen?
Du bist doch krasser Soldat
Warum kannst du hier nicht hoch
Und dieses Geplitze von irgendwelchen Achievements und so ist auch übelstackig
Give me that fuck
Die holen wir uns
Next please
Weiter gehts so muss das sein
Progas
Hallo ich will retzen
Ich will retzen ich dachte
Ah jetzt dachte ich doch
Hätte klappen können
Übrigens Rättsanimation finde ich immer noch
Ein Ticken zu lang
Weil letztendlich das schöne
Das schöne an Medics ist dass in der Regel
Also wenn gute Leute Medics spielen
Dann ist das gut für sie und das Team
Weil die quasi nebenbei noch das Team supporten können
Es werden quasi wenn gute Leute solo spielen
Werden sie immer die Klasse nehmen
Wo du am wenigsten auf das Team angewiesen bist
Das ist einfach so
Weil verlässt du dich publik komplett auf das Team
Bist quasi verloren
Was nicht heißen soll da ich mir das übertrieben gut in dem Game einschätzen würde
Aber Leute die wirklich gut sind
Du spielst automatisch Klassen
Also die Owner sagen wir es mal so
Die Owner spielen automatisch Klassen wo sie
Alleine gut klarkommen und wenn man quasi jetzt
Jemand der Owens quasi dazu zwingt
Lange Rättsanimation zu machen wird das dazu führen
Dass sie Medics spielen allerdings nicht retzen
Weil es ja für sie selbst extrem gefährlich ist
Was Blödsinn ist
Du musst quasi jemand der gut ist und quasi das Team carried plus wiederbeleben
Kann auch noch dazu unterstützen indem du ihm ermöglicht
Quasi Team Support zu machen während er Owens
Was halt mit langen Wiederbelebanimationen nicht geht
Versteht man was ich meine
Weil in der Regel hast du quasi dadurch dass das Medic in der Regel die Klasse ist
Die alleine am besten zurechtkommt
Hast du schon mal einen super hohen Supportanteil
Also quasi Heal und Rätts für das Team
Du musst den Leuten aber halt auch ermöglichen das zu machen
Ohne dass sie sich zu sehr in ihrem Spiel einschränken müssen
Sonst hast du 30 Medics im Team und davon retzen
25 nicht
Guck mal wie wir Oundi übrigens gerade über uns weg
Piss dich
Ich brauche die Munition
Und diese Rage doll Rack doll Dinger sind auch
Komisch
Okay das war jetzt zu viel
Das war zu viel
Das kann man mal aufnehmen
War das eine ganz coole Runde bis jetzt
Geh weg
The enemy has planes
Dieser der gezwungene deutsche Akzent ist schau mal Wahnsinn
Es ruckelt
Warum ruckelt
Darf nicht ruckeln
Ich hab den schnellsten Rechner den man kaufen kann zur Zeit
Das Game darf nicht ruckeln
In Low Settings
Ich muss mal kurz hier weg
Okay
War das der gleiche Typ der mich gekillt
Ja ne von der Seite
Wir haben es übelst gereckt
Guck dir das mal an
Nice
Oder hat sich das wieder gesettet
Ich hab es vorher vorhin auf Low Settings umgestellt
Übrigens man darf man auch in diesen komischen Intro Outro keine Settings umstellen
Darf es auch nervig
1080 Ti ist einfach deutlich zu langsam für das Spiel
Man muss halt auch mal die Wahrheit ins Gesicht sehen
Jetzt dürfen wir uns wieder ein schönes Intro angucken
Das war doch eine ganz schöne Runde
Alternativ könnte man auch einen Deutschen mit einem deutschen Akzenter sprechen lassen
Ich finde man hört immer so richtig raus wenn die Sprecher quasi versuchen deutschen
Akzent zu machen
Ich gucke jetzt noch mal, aber relativ sicher habe ich Lore
Ja hier, low, bis auf ein bisschen Anti-Alasing
Ähm, die spawnen alle hier ja, bester
Linke Seite sind der Regel zu bevorzugen auf der Map am Anfang
Sowohl als Attack als auch auf Defense
So hier kann es sein, dass man auf den Sack kriegt oder zwei Leute out
Kommt drauf an
Das ist immer gutes Opening
Ich hab die Map schon ein bisschen studiert
Okay, das war jetzt natürlich für den Arsch
Das passiert ja halt, das passiert halt von allen Seiten
Aber Opening auf der Map ist am besten, wenn du es immer auf die linke Seite machst
Ich hab das Dunelöner, genau, ich hab das Game direkt outgefigert
So ist es
Okay, er gibt keinen Rätsel, kann er auch gar nicht
Da steht er irgendwo rum, sonst wo
Das war hier Spawn
Und das ist auch ein Punkt den ich nicht verstehe
Man klickt auf der Map auf den Spawn-Punkt und man spawnt ganz woanders
Habt ihr es gesehen, ich hab auf diesen Spawn-Punkt da geklickt
Da würde man davon ausgehen, man spawnt hier auch irgendwo
Aber nein, man spawnt da
Das ist ein Drittel der Map weiter weg vom Spawn-Punkt
Wo man sich denkt, warum ist dann der Spawn-Punkt da auf der Map wo man spawnen kann
Wenn man doch da nicht spawnen
Weiß man nicht, genau
Ich wollte eigentlich gerade messern
Ich hör sie links neben, recht neben mir laufen
Ich hab Schiss
Ich verrecke jetzt, wenn sie die Flankerino-Action macht
Okay, ich hau ab
Ich hau ab
Lack hier
Gibt es Counter-Messern?
Ich glaube nicht
So, jetzt kann man nämlich hier hoch
Wenn diese Scheiß-Animation funktioniert, kann man hier hoch und nicht von oben bashen
Das Problem ist, seht ihr diese Animation, das ist so fail, dass Animationen nicht funktionieren
Du musst fünfmal klicken, dass diese Scheiß-Animation kommt
Und ich hab's mit Ankündigung, das war mit Ankündigung
Ich geh jetzt da hoch und dann werden sie gebashed, aber ich bin nicht hochgekommen
Kacke, Sackblödsinn
Ansonsten kam auch schon ganz gut bash in dem Game
Das ist schon recht nice
Wenn das noch alles ein bisschen präziser wird, also sprich, dass du auch das Gefühl
hast, du hast die Kontrolle, was passiert in dem Game, dann wird das bash fest
825, kannst nix ahre
Ach so, spotten ist übrigens random, ich weiß
Da hab ich bis jetzt nämlich gecheckt, wie man spottet richtig
Au, ein Gegner, ja, nicht gesehen
Also was ich zum spotten schon probiert hab, oh Rats, danke, nice, nice
Was ich zum spotten schon probiert hab, ist gucken, Q drücken, Q drücken und gucken
So und manchmal spottet er dann, ich weiß nicht genau wann
Aber es ist doof, das ist wirklich doof
Und das, wie die Sonne blämmt, ist auch krass
Ich bin hier ein bisschen exposed
Die gucken da zu, wie das Kriegsrat gebacken
Ok, ich umlaufe die jetzt mal ein bisschen, was ist das hier?
Ein Gewehr, ein Gewehr ohne Munition, ok, dann nehm ich lieber meins wieder
Oh, Muni, ah, Pistole, das ist eine Sache, die mir in dem Game wirklich gut gefällt,
man muss ja mal was positives sagen
Die Pistolen sind nice
Also die Pistolen gefallen mir gut, also oft, natürlich nur oft, na, oh da ist, da ist,
Muni, GIF, nice, ganze zwölf Schuss
Ganze zwölf Schuss
Wieder keine Schuss, ok, wow, ich muss hier weg
Alter, haut ab
Ok, wo sind Gegner, haben wir Gegner, ach da hinten, fuck
Hier, hier steht ne Munikiss
Also meistens steht hier ne Munikiss, jetzt steht gerade keine Munikisse da
Also, ach die ist kaputt, ok
Die Munikiss ist kaputt, das ist unglücklich
Rätts, Yolo Rätts, ich kann nicht ratzen, geht nicht, Animation ging nicht
Ah, der Panzmann ist am Start
Ich hör den, der Panzer
Ja gut, 3-3-5, man kann ja auch irgendwann mal sterben
Es wäre cool, wenn es so ne, so ne Kombination gäbe, quasi, dass man, das war so ne, man
hatte ja in Battlefield 3 war das glaub ich, da hattest du ja so ne Perk für mehr Munition,
das wär hier wirklich praktisch
Wo du es dann auch als Team Perk nehmen konntest, das war schon nice
Irgendwo rechts war hier doch was, wo ist er?
Auf Range ist halt die Sub-Maschinen alles übelst räudig, deswegen mein ich, das sind
da auch viel zu wenig Schuss
Da unten war doch noch einer, oder?
Ach ne
Das ist die, dann zappeln die Gegner auch so
Du denkst, warum zappeln die so
Muss weg
Yolo Yolo
Yolo, auf, komm her, bashen, Pistolen-Basch
Du wirst dich hier laufen am Pistolen-Baschen, weil du keine Munition mehr hast
GIF, GIF Ammo, GIF please, please
Kann man sich aus denen noch was rausnehmen, geht das hier auch?
Pech gehabt, oh, die Musik ist fertig, wir müssen, next
Oh, oh, ich lebe wieder
Pech
Aber 37,6 läuft, läuft noch nice
Übrigens, falls ich was überlese, ich konzentriere mich gerade relativ stark auf Scam, schreib
das ganze Loch hier mit Ed, Ed Wubblors, entschättern, dass, dass ich's sehe
Sparren, Kollege, sparren
Spock dich, auf
Hallo, spawnen, no longer available, aber ich seh ihn doch
Fake News
Wow, ich hab einfach mal 416 Punkte gekriegt für, für, ich weiß nicht so genau
Und ich, ich hab die Killstreak-Taste schon wieder vergessen
Was war nochmal die Killstreak-Taste?
Yolo Reds
Leute, wisst ihr nochmal, was die Killstreak-Taste war?
Kann mir das grad nochmal einer sagen, das war die Killstreak-Taste
Es gibt ja Killstreaks in dem Gamebus, zwar, was war die Killstreak-Taste?
Da kippt was, ja, über Range zacken die halt, die Sackmaschinen, dann sind wir sich auch
ok, das ist ja vollkommen legitim, das ist vollkommen legitim, dass es zackt übrigens
über Range
Alter, Panzer, kannst du mal abhauen?
Ich hab Schiss
Ich hab wirklich Schiss, der Panzer
Ich hab Angst, dass der mich debatet, oder jetzt ausgestiegen ist, oder so
Fuck
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich bin
Ok, hier ist nichts, ist schlecht
Ok, ich muss hier weg, der Panzer ist immer noch vor mir
Jaja, ist gut, hau ab
Wir gehen jetzt mal hier rüber
Oh, oh, die pushen hier ganz schön hart rein
Vielleicht kommen wir hier durch, wenn wir Glück haben, können wir unten noch ein bisschen
aufräumen
Ok, das war ein bisschen doof von mir
Da waren ein bisschen viele
Ja, die Runde ging gut los, war jetzt grad ein bisschen kacke
Next
Äh, eigentlich wollte ich da spawnen
Ja, spawnen wir halt da
Guck mal, da bin ich gespawned und ich spawn wieder nach einem Drittel Map hinten dran
Das ist total im Vier
Wenn sie mir schon anzeigen, dass ich an B spawne, dann sollte ich halt auch an B spawnen
Bei denen stimmt gar nichts
Ich hab mich verguckt
Vergesst was ich gesagt hab, ich bin ja gar nicht B gespawned
Hier sind Gegner 100 pro, müssen
Aber ich glaub hier vorne ist das Map aus
Da hinten waren welche
Alter heil dich, ich hab 5 gedrückt
Ok, das ist kacke, stehen zu viele Gegner da
Äh, ja stimmt, genau, was war der Knopf nochmal für die Killstreaks
Ich weiß den Knopf dafür nicht mehr
Die werden jetzt gebashed
Welche Reload werden die jetzt, gehen wir da rum
Wow, von wo, weiß es nicht
Ich will den spotten, ich darf den nicht spotten
Ok, random Headshot von sonst wo
Es ist so fail, warum kann ich die Gegner nicht spotten vor mir, was soll das
Weiß ich, ich hab den angeguckt, ich hab da Q gedrückt
Warum, was soll das Kacke, es ist ja nicht schon genug Anreiz Recon Camp Kacke zu spielen
Was in jedem Battlefield die Best ist
Kannst doch nicht nur einen Recon spotten lassen
Das geht doch nicht
Sieht nix
Welche Seite kommen sie
Kommen sie oben, kommen sie unten
Die zweite Phase von der Map hab ich noch nicht so richtig gecheckt
Da hab ich jetzt oben drauf
Ich fahr ja schon lange auf dem Rückweg
Aber die Animation hat halt wieder zu lange gedauert
Ich hasse dieses, mir geht das wirklich
Also wenn ich eine Sache an dem Spiel sagen müsste, was mich wirklich nervt und was auch
der Hauptgrund ist, das was mich vom Kauf abhält, dann ist es diese Animation
Du hast für jeden Scheiß irgendeine Animation, in der du nix machen kannst
Ich mein die sollen mich einfach spielen lassen
Es ist doch egal ob ich jetzt schön von der Kiste runter steige oder nicht
Hauptsache ich komm von der Kiste schnell runter, wenn ich von der Kiste runter will
Hier ist irgendwo ein Map aus oder, war hier nicht ein Map aus, hier ist ein Map aus
Hau!
Das geht aber nix gerade
Zack
Wir müssen mal irgendwie eine gute Flankgeschichte hinkriegen
Gucken wir mal rechte Seite
Ich werde zum Squad Leader Promoted werden
Da war einer
ZF
Ich hab irgendwie ein schneller Nachladen anlockt für die Waffe
Man merkt es ein bisschen, also das scheint schon Effekt zu haben
Ich dachte ich kann hier wiederbeleben
Overrated, gebated, outdated
Au, was ist hier los, Alter
Wo ist der Gegner
Ich würde ihn jetzt gerne spotten, aber ich kann ja nicht
Das geht ja nicht
Hat es das Gamer gedacht
Scheiß Balken
Scheiß Balken, ey
Geht es irgendwann weiter mit den Programming Streams
Ja, auf jeden Fall
Jetzt muss man mal ein Meme-Bot mehr verwenden
Das ist die ganze Zeit an und ich verwende es nicht
Voll verschenktes Potential
Bei dem spawn ich nicht, das sieht mir ein bisschen zu
Hier, Ramon KS aus
Werther ist weg
Und was man jetzt hier auch wieder schön sieht, dass es halt keine Frontlinien in dem
Sinn gibt
Bei Rush, deswegen ist Rush auch mein Lieblingsspielmodus
Bei Rush kannst du, wenn du mitdenkst, eigentlich
Bei Rush machst du es eigentlich hauptsächlich indem du gut einschätzen kannst, wie die
sich bewegen
Und zu 99% klappt das immer
Das geht hier nicht
Das ist total random
Das Ebaro ist off-line
Ich muss mal hier weg
Yolo, Jump
Das sind Low-Settings
Das ist auch wieder so ein Problem, dass Gegner auf der Erde rumzappeln und man sie
nicht sieht richtig
Ob sie leben, krabbeln, also ob sie tot sind, ob sie leben, noch krabbeln oder nicht
Alter, dieses Game
What the fuck
Nein
Oh
MonkaS
Übels MonkaS
Das ist der MonkaS, der MonkaS
Komm her
Herzen
Leute, so sieht es aus, wenn jemand zusammengeflickt wird
Ich flicke dich zusammen
Das ist auch fürs Wiederbeleben übels
Nein
Nein, nein, wir losten nicht, Bertha.
Bertha wird nicht gelostet.
Hahaha, Kleine!
Ich wollte gerade
FSK 18
erzählen, das geht ja nicht.
Hahaha,
was ein Typ, ey!
LOL!
Was ist das für ein Gegner, ey?
Was ist das für ein Gegner?
Ja, ich hab gerade so aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen,
dass jemand was von Unlocks geschrieben hat
im...
Chat?
Wo ich sagen muss, ja, bin ich auch kein Fan von,
wie sie das gemacht haben.
Dass du quasi
Waffen unlocks irgendwie.
Guck, du weißt, das ist so fail.
Du weißt nicht, ob der Typ, eben hat er gerade noch gezappelt, ne?
Du weißt nicht, ob der Tod ist?
Oder ob der, ob der krabbelt?
Das ist so fail, wer hat sich das ausgedacht?
Alter, könnte ich mich da drüber aufregen.
Ja, renn schön mit deinem Kopf rein,
obst du kein Problem mit.
Links?
Oder auch nicht?
Was ist das hier?
Kaukt das was?
Oh ne, ich brauch was anderes, ich brauch was anderes.
Gib, gib ordentlich Waffe.
Ich geh einfach zurück zum Money-Thing.
Hallo.
Alter.
Da ist ein Panzer hinter uns.
Ich wusste gar nicht, ob ich sich hier rein verstecken kann.
Hüpf, hüpf, hüpf.
Krasser Soldat, hüpf hoch, please.
Es kommt ne Granate.
Es kommt ne Granate, ja, so siehts aus.
Besche, besche, besche, besche, besche.
Hier ist nix.
Außer, außer von das Alte.
Da ist was.
Ja Chris, du weißt doch,
die größten Hater sind die größten Fans.
Ist so.
Die, die sich am meisten mit den Games beschäftigen,
sind auch die, die sich am meisten mit den Games aufregen,
weil sie die Games am besten kennen.
Uh, der hier.
Wo wir wieder bei Frontlinien sind, ne.
Spawn, hinter einem Tod.
Aber wobei das Argument jetzt in dem Fall
ja gar nicht zutrifft.
Es ist ne Beta, die kostet nix.
Wo man ja wunderbar schon mal ausprobieren kann,
ob man das Spiel sich holen will oder nicht.
Battlefield 1 Beta fand ich so schlimm,
dass ich mir das Game nicht geholt hab.
Ich hab noch nicht mal den Code eingelöst,
den ich hatte.
Wollte das Game nicht.
Jetzt letztens hat mir der Mesh noch nen Code gegeben,
da dachte ich, okay, jetzt löse ich's ein.
Also sprich ich aber noch, wenn man quasi noch,
dann kann man ja nicht nein sagen, ja.
Oh, ich spiel's nicht.
Suckergamer.
Wo ist er denn?
Viel zu viel in dem Haus drinnen.
Fuck.
Und wer ist der Erste, der runterläuft und verreckt?
Ich. Natürlich, was sonst.
Übrigens, der Henkel-Shelf-Horse,
der ist richtig gut da unten.
Den Sinn dieser stationären Dinger,
glaub die verwendet keiner.
Was? Anton kann nicht Losted werden.
Ich bin direkt dran.
Hä?
Fuck.
Jetzt sieht man, wie schlecht manche Leute sind, ey.
Ich treu dich.
Gegenüber ist einer.
Weiß nicht genau, oh, da.
Das Schneibern, da.
Was sonst? Ja, immer schön in der Ecke sitzen und Schneibern.
Das können alle.
Ich bin krasser Schneibern.
Was gibt's denn für geile Filmschneiber?
Äh.
Sagt mal einen.
Gibt doch bestimmt irgendwelche Filme mit geilen
Snipern drinnen.
Wollen alle geile Snipern sein hier,
weil es sich da geil vorkommt.
Jetzt wollen wir mal Auto ausprobieren.
Äh.
Ach, da sitzt schon ein Typ am Turm.
Lol.
Hätte ich als unbelegt an uns gedacht.
Was ist das?
Oh. Das war ein Killstreak,
übrigens. Wir haben uns auch vorhin gefragt, wie ein
Killstreak aussieht. So sieht ein Killstreak aus.
Jetzt
muss man sehen, wie ein Killstreak aussieht.
So sieht ein Killstreak aus.
What?
Warum? Warum?
Ey!
Wird der gerade gefickt oder was?
Was ist das?
KappaPride? Was? Was? Was? Was? Was? Was? Was macht der da auf dem Boden?
Boah.
Fuck.
Übrigens, der Spawn ist auch
übelst unfair, ne?
Oh, das wird die erste Runde mit sechs Kills?
Weiß.
Wäre das zwischendurch nicht so kacke gelaufen,
hätten wir noch mehr.
Ich glaube, 60er hat schon etwas.
Spawn.
So Leute, ich würde auch gerne mal Killstreaks wahren.
Was ist denn die Taste für Killstreaks?
Sagen wir halt mal einer.
War das nicht V halten oder so?
Das war so ganz merkwürdig.
Machen wir
die fette Dissektor.
Hier ist Karten aus.
Die
Karten aus-Dinger sind auch
übelst, ne? Hier ist nichts. Warum
ist hier bitte schon Karten aus? Hier ist nichts.
Wisst ihr, auf den Rushmaps in Bad Company,
da hat man es ja ungefähr noch versucht,
sinnvoll zu erklären, wo Karten aus ist.
Da ging es dann halt einen Berg hoch und danach
war Karten aus, weil man da offiziell nicht drüber kam.
Aber was ist das hier?
Obwohl man da vorher auf den Teil der Map
konnte, aus welchen Gründen, aus welchen
irgendwie erdenkbaren Gründen
kann man jetzt nicht mehr,
ich darf nicht ratzen, sollte man jetzt nicht mehr
auf diese Maphälfte können.
Das gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Oh.
Jetzt will er so ein Ding.
Bam.
Übrigens, Leute, wo ist der
Kill-Feed? Fällt mir gerade auf.
Wo ist der Kill-Feed?
Ernsthaft?
Wo ist der Kill-Feed? Ich sehe den.
Wo ist der Kill-Feed?
Der ist weg.
Canst du an- und ausstellen?
Na ja, okay, okay. Muss ich gleich mal
machen. Erinnert mich mal bitte
mit dran, dass ich Kill-Feed.
Alter!
Da fuck!
Was war das?
Das ist in dem Game, das sind so merkwürdige
Dinger.
Hä?
Ich check, dass es geändert hat.
Mein Problem ist, ich habe keine
Buni mehr.
Was?
Alter, was ist mit der Waffe los?
Das Game macht mich fertig.
Warum hat die sich jetzt verbogen?
Das Game macht mich wirklich
übelst
fertig im Kopf.
Ich denke immer,
das ist ein Kopf.
Aber ist das kein Kopf?
Gebaited, sage ich dazu nur.
Massiver
Gebaited.
Damage machen, Blitz.
Kann man das hier aufstellen?
Es ist so hakelig.
Es ist so hakelig. Hallo!
Stell doch mal please dein Ding hier auf.
Falls du was dran hast, keine Ahnung.
Ah shit.
Jetzt habe ich es verkackt.
Ach, Kill-Feeds kann man noch als Squad leaden.
Ah!
Deswegen kann ich keine Kill-Feeds holen.
Okay.
Ah, das ist ja okay. Das ist okay.
Das, ähm,
ist legitim.
Das lasse ich mir gefallen.
Wir flanken jetzt wieder unten rum.
Wie gehen wir denn das Haus?
Das war ein guter Spot.
Äh,
schreck mich nicht so.
Ich dachte, wo da was da oben los ist.
Das mit dem Bauen muss ich mir auch noch angucken.
Oh, Panzer.
Band.
Instant Band.
Wir haben verloren.
Haha, ja, ich hab's jetzt gelesen.
Als, als hab ich quasi den kompletten Sinn des Games im Chat noch nicht gelesen.
Oh, hier ist das Map aus.
Der wird jetzt gebashed.
Oh, fuck, bin der Arsch geschossen.
Was für Kills zieht das Alter Vier drücken?
Schlechter Chebat.
Sehr schlechter Chebat.
Kriegen wir noch die 70 Kills voll.
Ease.
Two Ease.
Wir stehen hier gerade irgendwie mit einem Gegner spawn, ne?
Mehr oder weniger.
Komm, die 70 kriegen wir noch.
Was?
Der hatte 15 Schuss drinne.
War das Spawn-Immunity?
Das war Spawn-Immunity, hä?
Das muss Spawn-Immunity gewesen sein.
Ja, das war 100% Spawn-Immunity.
Das war mehr.
Rats.
Chebat-Protection war das.
Ja.
Ist halt geile Waffe auf Range.
Ah, Spawn-Protection.
Bäh.
Spawn-Protection 2k18.
Ease.
Wollen wir danach mal...
...versuchen, ob wir eine Runde Conquest...
Ich mein, ich spiel halt nicht gerne Conquest,
muss ich dazu sagen.
Bäh.
Ich spiel halt nicht gerne Conquest,
und ich bin das auch nicht sonderlich...
...gut beim Conquest spielen.
Alter, was ist hier los?
Da können wir aber zumindest bei Rotterdam spielen.
Ja, Spawn-Protection auf...
...Member Spawn verstehe ich eh nicht.
Wenn man, wenn man...
...der Milchmann, wenn man halt kacke spawnt,
ist man selbst... NEIN!
Keine 70 Kills gepackt.
Nooo.
60-9-größer, 70-4, da ist auch was dran.
Was bleibt von unseren Stärken in den Berge?
Wir liegen im Wachstum.
Reicht auf einen neuen Horizont,
ein neuer Horizont durch die Killing-Halm.
Das war keine Spawn-Protection?
Dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ich mein, der hat wirklich...
...das waren 15 Kugeln da so in dem Typ drinne.
Oh.
Jetzt die Frage...
Gameplay, ha?
Kill... Killlock...
Chat...
Also Chat machen wir mal an.
Chat muss man immer anmachen,
dass man ein bisschen Geflame sehen kann.
Ähm...
Killlock wird's wahrscheinlich sein.
Da schon ein bisschen dummes Zeug zum Chat schreiben.
Ah, ich hätte die Waffe noch upgraden können.
Ich hab jetzt bestimmt genug Punkte.
Aber eigentlich will ich...
eigentlich will ich Medic Level 10 machen und dann...
Wir machen jetzt wieder unser Zug-Opening.
Ähm...
Also ich will jetzt Medic Level 10 machen und dann...
und dann MP40 anlocken.
Also MP40 anlocken.
MP40 anlocken und dann...
Warum hab ich so viele Zuschauer heute?
Ich hab's ja nicht mal auf Twitter gepostet.
Das kriegt eigentlich gar keiner mit.
Ähm, kann jede Klasse bauen?
Ich hab eigentlich keine Ahnung von dem Game.
Kann jede Klasse bauen? Und wenn ja, wie baut man?
Hier an diesen Dingern kann man bauen, ne?
Ja, da oben mit dem Hammer. Wie kommt man auf den Hammer?
Was? MP40 ist kacke?
Echt? MP40 war in der Alpha übertrieben geil.
Also mega geil.
T drücken?
Ja, Minecraft-Style.
Au! Voll in your face!
Was ist hier los?
In den...
Muss nicht sterben. Freimann-Kopfgeschirr muss nicht sterben.
Das ist komplett overrated.
Jetzt...
Next...
Oh!
Ah, shit.
Das hätte... Huge Plays hätten das werden können.
Big Plays. Aber leider sind wir verreckt.
Warum kann man mich nicht abonnieren? Weil ich keine...
Kein Twitch-Partner bin.
Kannst du mich auf YouTube abonnieren?
Dann kannst du mal.
Wenn ich mal wieder was hochladen würde.
The Squad Sucked.
King! The Squad King. Das klingt gut.
Gehen wir jetzt.
Äh.
Hallo?
The Squad? King?
Battlefield! Dice!
Komm an, Bra!
Okay.
Squad-System kaputt.
Spawn?
Spawnen? Jawoll.
Wie immersive ist das Game?
Das ist ja das immersive Game, das ich je gespielt habe.
Vor allem Spawn-Bugs sind super immersive.
Das ist nämlich in echt auch passiert.
Ihr müsst euch mal Aufzeichnungen von damals durchgucken.
Da haben sich ganz viele Leute
beschwert.
So 1942 rum.
Spawn Bug.
Spawn.
Scherben, please.
Was geht hier eigentlich gerade ab?
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Tango Sucker.
Beste Sounds.
Code 4 hatte die besten Sounds was das angeht.
Tango Sucker.
Oder
Gab's da sonst noch?
Irgendwas Arabisches, was ich nicht aussprechen kann.
Hayabiner, Hayabiner.
Hallo.
Jetzt ab.
Jetzt rennen sie aber gereckt, oder?
Ok, was noch immer.
Alter, hör auf zu brennen.
Brennen.
Das gehört sich nicht.
Ben overrated.
Auch hinter uns ist einer.
Was macht denn der da?
Hat es dem irgendjemand erlaubt da hinzustellen?
Da unten ist er.
Nee.
Du bist einfach nur so reingespawned.
Was hast du, Alter?
Komm her, geb her.
Was ist das?
SDG für den 40.
Nice.
Aber keine Money dafür.
Oh, oh.
Ha.
Noob.
Spawn eine Waffe.
Give weapon please.
So.
Hier gibt es nichts.
Keine Waffe.
Vielleicht beim Schenkelhorst.
Oder wie das heißt.
Hengschelphorst.
Da gibt es bestimmt eine Waffe.
Ah, da ist was.
Weg, Waffe.
Hinwerfen, heilen.
Gegner, bashen.
So geht das, Leute.
Oh.
13-1.
Nice.
An den Flanken sind Munikisten.
Ich sehe die trotzdem im Eifern des Gefechts immer nicht.
Spawnen.
Please spawnen.
Oh, wo sind wir denn hier gespawned?
Es war sehr gefährlich hier zu spawnen.
In den Kopf.
Kann ich dir nicht eine Kiste geben?
Ah, guck mal, da ist eine Hitkiste.
The enemy is winning.
Das sieht für mich nicht so aus, als winnt der enemy gerade.
Der enemy kriegt gerade auf den Sack.
Das sieht für euch so aus, als winnt der enemy.
Für mich sieht es aus, als kriegt der enemy gerade mega auf den Sack.
Komm mal.
Ah, nice.
Schön drauf.
Der enemy kriegt gerade einfach nur extrem auf den Sack.
Oh, nice.
Muni.
Jetzt bin ich spotty, welcher Knopf ist das denn?
Also es kann mir keiner nachsagen, dass in dem Game nicht geohnt wird.
Ich brauch Muni.
Nice.
Wieder hoch.
Wo ist er?
Den jucken enemy planes.
Komm her.
War der nicht hier?
Haha, Kollege ist auch nicht.
Scheiße, da war noch einer.
Ich bin das Squash Leader, ja.
B.
Echt B?
Wahrscheinlich bin ich nicht down.
Help, help, retz, please.
Alter, ich bin der, der die Gegner killt.
Ihr müsst mich retzen.
Retz mich doch, so schwer kann es doch nicht sein.
Alle ihr kleinen...
Ja, ja, ja, retz mich.
Retz mich, retz mich.
Passt.
Alter, please.
Was ist denn hier los? Ich muss hier weg.
So, B muss man drücken.
Okay, B.
B passiert nix.
B.
Debated.
Hinter uns.
Haha, die Noobs, ey.
Als Gefecht.
So macht es doch Spaß.
Fuck, ich hab kaum noch Muni.
Ich brauch Muni.
Pistolnext und Pistolnext sind immer der beste.
Ah, ich hab wieder Muni. Jawoll.
26,3.
Jetzt werden sie geschreckt.
Die Gegner sind so schlecht.
Ja, nice, bau, bau.
Bauding.
Perfekt, wie in das T.
Ja, hallo, lass mich bauen.
Please, bauen.
So, jetzt bauen wir mal.
Minecraft Simulator.
Hallo, bauen.
Bauen?
Ich bin zu dumm für das Game.
Ich kann nur killen.
Ich kann nur killen, ich kann sonst nix in dem Game.
Guck mal.
Ich kann nicht bauen.
Warum nicht?
Das ist von mir, warum kann ich nicht bauen?
Leute, ihr baut, ich kille.
Das ist gut.
Ich kille und retze.
Da ist schon gebaut.
Ach so.
Woher weiß man, wo man Wände bauen kann und wo man nur Sandstöcke bauen kann?
Ich muss hier mal kurz weg.
Ist mir ein bisschen zu gefährlich.
Da wo die ist, baut man ja.
Ich sehe es.
Moment, ich war hinter dem Ding.
Der kommt hier gleich raus.
Da ist noch einer dahinter.
Ach so.
Das war anders geplant.
Das war nicht so geplant, Leute.
Ich wollte es eigentlich rauswerfen.
Was ist denn hier los?
Ja, versteck dich.
Ich will mit Ammo spawnen.
Perfekt.
Jetzt kommt die krasse Flank-Action.
SMG ist im Toll auf Range.
Echt, so muss es sein.
32-4 in your face.
Muss klatschen, muss es.
Dazu gibt es dann eigentlich auch nur noch zu sagen.
Rotterdam.
Ja, Medic Level 10.
Die Runde mache ich noch fertig.
Das ist ja noch nicht fertig.
Das war jetzt nur Attack.
Moment, ich habe eingebaut, dass man den beschleunigen kann.
Kogas?
Kogas, Speed Kogas.
Genauso wie Lul und Lul 4D.
Das Spiel im Hintergrund läuft.
Omega Kogas, ja.
Ja, linke Seite.
Klar, was sonst.
Wir machen wieder unser Opening, wo man nicht genau weiß, wie es wird.
Es kann gut sein oder nicht gut sein.
Das Opening kann gut sein oder nicht gut sein.
Jetzt ist es gerade ganz gut.
Out of ammo.
Was war das denn?
Moment, der hat mich mit der gleichen Waffe gekillt, die ich habe.
Hat sich das so angefühlt, als hätte er mehr als einmal geschossen?
In your face war das.
Lass dich mal nicht beschießen.
Ok, dann nicht.
Spawnen.
Aber 6 und 3 Schufe, die werden krass gerecht wieder die Runde.
Oma, Toxic Chat.
Das ist ein Overwatch.
So, genug Dreadstalk im Chat.
Weiter geht's.
Ich will hier drauf, lasst aber diese Scheiß-Animation funktionieren.
Animation of Doom.
Hier oben ist übrigens Top 10.
Das ist ein Superspot.
Wenn man halt Gegner hat.
Wo sind die Gegner?
Yolo-Charge über die Lok.
Ist das gerade Spawn-Rape oder so?
Kann das sein?
Das sieht mir so ein bisschen nach Spawn-Rape aus, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
So minimal.
Komm her, schräg dich.
Das ist echt gut programmiert.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie es ist beim fünften Spiel auf Frostbite.
Jetzt hab ich was vergessen.
Suche Gegner, die haben schon alles eingenommen.
Das ist einfach.
So.
Nicht in die Richtung laufen.
Sonst kann man sie nicht owen.
Dann klatscht es.
Was ist das?
Was haben die Leute wieder?
Wir gehen unten lang.
Linke Seite, linke Seite.
Die Berta wurde getankt.
Kann es sein, dass dieses Jübel anflammt?
Das finde ich auch fällig.
Ich will an B spawnen.
Ich spawne 150 Meter weit weg.
B plus 150 später.
Die Berta ist verloren.
Wir flanken.
Die Wehrmacht konnte auch nicht an B spawnen.
Das Problem ist, dass du RL gar nicht spawnen kannst.
Die Phase ist vorbei.
Ich gehe auf die andere Seite.
So wie gefühlt das halbe Team.
Wir ärgern den Typen.
Wir flamen noch mehr.
Hier ist es aus.
Wo ist der nächste?
Ich gehe schon zurück.
Die Berta wurde getankt.
Was hat er noch geschrieben?
Das ist King the Veteran.
Die Berta wurde getankt.
Das nervt mich.